[موسيقى]
عندما تركت سوريا اعتقدت انها النهايه
يعني من اجل التعليم ومن اجل مستقبلي بما
يخص التعليم لذلك عندما وصلنا للمخيم كان
هناك مدرسه فذلك اعطاني يعني امل كبير لان
اصنع يعني مستقبل جميل جدا وان اتحدى كل
الظروف
[موسيقى]
الصعبه بدات في حمله كنت اذهب يعني من
مكان الى اخر من خيمه الى اخرى من اي اسره
الى اخرى كي احدثهم عن التعليم وان اشجعهم
ان لا يفقدوا الامل وان يتعلموا واننا
نحتاج الى كل طفل هو خارج سوريا حاليا
وداخل سوريا يعني اي طفل سوري اي في اي
مكان كان ان يتعلم وان لا يفقد الامل
لاننا نحتاج التعليم للجميع يعني ليس فقط
لشخص واحد ونريد كل الاطفال ان يحصلوا على
[موسيقى]
حقهم كي يكون المجتمع ككل مجتمع قوي
ويستطيع حقا ان ينهب وان يتطور يجب ان
تتعلم المراه ايضا لذلك يعني اتمنى انه
جميع النساء يؤمنوا بانفسهم وان يتعلمن
وان يعلمن ان التعليم سلاح مهم
[موسيقى]
جدا انا طبعا اتشرف ان يطلق علي ملاله
سوريا وهذا شيء يعني افتخر به تماما ولكن
انا لدي قصتي الخاصه ولدي صوتي يعني انا
احب ان اقارن نفسي يعني بنفسي ك كمزون وان
تكون يعني ان يعلم الناس ان مزون يعني
لديها ايضا قصتها الخاصه وظروفها الخاصه
على الرغم يعني انا ومل لا نتشارك في نفس
الشيء لكن لكل منا حياتها الخاصه وظروفه
وما مر به كان مختلفا تماما جعلتني طبعا
هذه التجربه اكثر حكمه وادركت فيها قوه
صوتي يعني ان اكون انسانه ليس فقط مؤثره
لنفسي كمزون بل استطيع ان احدث تغييرا
عالميا وهذا الشيء انا فخوره جدا فيه يعني
اذا كنت اريد ان اتحدث عن اكبر الانجازات
التي انجزتها في حياتي في هذه العشر سنوات
هي انني ادركت انني اعطي الامل
[موسيقى]
للاخرين استمري ولا تفقدي الامل مهما كانت
الظروف صعبه يجب ان تدركي انه يوما ما
تستطيعين تحقيق ما
[موسيقى]
تريدين
ه